[Musique]
ce qui est rageant bailly qu il pose un
champ droit dont l'un des joyaux de
portions ya un loup
[Musique]
à genève devra
erreur
sharon stone
m
let the sunshine in to web
télé
il convient aussi de noter
ce n'est pas cher vis dudley mon désir
pour vous grandit en même temps que la
distance qui nous sépare
j'ai traversé toute l'europe après avoir
passé les lugubres montagne de
transylvanie
j'ai atteint les forêts sauvages de la
petite russie
j'ai vu une créature ancestrale avec des
yeux innombrables elle s'appelait dit
permettez moi de me présenter je
m'appelle johnattan grille je suis un
scientifique spécialiste de la
cartographie ça vient de johnatan il a
détruit j'ai modifié le trajet de mon
voyage afin de venir voir votre fameux
dragon
il semblerait qu'il fasse actuellement
route vers la chine en compagnie d'un
jeune homme chinois
j'ai une femme et ma fille tourne à
thann voyage en compagnie d'une fille
alors mettez social shy'm je vous
promets que la trouver
non ne touchez pas ça c'est le casque de
gengis khan
non cette annonce a appartenu à
alexandre le grand non non non non non
nous avons trouvé le sceau du dragon
il est entre les mains d'un noble russe
le tsar en personne pierre le grand
la sorcière après votre apparence tout
le monde croit qu'elle est lui
[Musique]
vous ne comprenez toujours pas où vous
êtes
comme je te redonne de voler jusqu'à
noir je m'appelle bill daly sco
je suis journaliste c'est pour les gens
qui ne croient pas en toi montait aussi
et journalistes
je savais pas que teresa
je viens d'arriver est ce que vous vous
connaissez tout était tranquille par ici
je t'aurais préféré
parce que tu as été aujourd'hui sur les
lieux du crime les milieux du crime
en quittant la ville et la jury de lui
remettrai jamais qui avons pourquoi en
le fils du maire a disparu mais on n'a
jamais su ce qui est arrivé à risque de
lasser a pas mon meilleur ami il a été
enlevé
juste devant moi je voulais voir une
copie du rapport de police richie faille
quelqu'un peut s'occuper de ça il n'est
pas question que je me mêle je peux pas
tout montrer mais voilà déjà ce que j'ai
vous m'aidez pourquoi je déteste aussi
les machos paternaliste jeune fille tu
ne sais pas du tout dans quoi tu mérite
qu on appelle toujours jeune fille comme
si c'était un compliment mais je sais
que ce n'est pas vraiment qu'est ce que
tu as fait je suis journaliste non à une
écolière ya toute une vie pleine de
personnes qui en savent plus que moi sur
l'homme que j'ai pris
et quelque chose que tu devrais savoir
qu'elle sèche et l'école pour aller
interroger le suspect du meurtre
non enfin oui mais non dans notre
famille on règle nos problèmes
[Musique]
ce
entre toi moi les miens je préfèrerais
me montrer courageuse tu devras être les
deux
[Musique]
le titre a reculé pour des matchs
je regrette en fait que tel
[Musique]
encore
discutant au sort
yu na
[Musique]
le ca
tout symbolique et ma sauvegarde
[Musique]
ce que tu arrives regarde donc pu
stopper de paris
en charge du cabinet
m cameron et s'ils lisent comme des fans
les palais
graille solo
[Musique]
deux jours plus tard à bangui
nouveau à la basse
wade m
[Musique]
je suis plus tout ça
morin
[Musique]
mes étudiants réaliser un film on m'a
dit que ce film était terrifiant plus de
la moitié des gens présents se sont
enfuis de la salle de cinéma quelqu'un a
eu une crise cardiaque et il en est mort
c'est quoi le titre
je le fais de ma ville finance il te
plait mon film
qui te fait peur
[Musique]
on est devant le portail qui n'ouvrent
pas la télécommande marche plus et
visiblement vous répondez pas votre
téléphone
c'est notre maison non pour l'instant
ils sont chez eux
il a signé un contrat non mais quel
contrat
soyez raisonnable et partez maintenant
sinon quoi
l'audience aura lieu le 9 novembre c'est
la trêve hivernale on va payer les
traites maison pour loger deux
squatteurs pendant qu'on vit vraiment
d'une caravane avec toi tu vis en
vacances
pas vraiment green way on t'écoute
si vous faites vos les tullistes un
faible ses parents je pense que tu es
une victime parce que tu as décidé de
l'être dit que c'est chez toi c'est chez
moi c'est chez toi roula quand on aura
un problème on sera bien obligé de le
régler tout seul cette société part en
couille
on ne fuit pas la peur savoure là
embrasse là c'est quoi le plan
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
à
[Musique]
voilà du doubs 4 sur 1000